this place is really cool it should have
been on my bucket list there's all these
mini people everywhere basically I'm
becoming my own Barbie this is called
ultimate bucket list we're all gonna
choose items from our bucket list to
determine what belongs on the ultimate
bucket list things that everyone should
try to do before you know they kick the
bucket we are in the home of newbies and
it's summertime what better thing to do
in the summer then go see a movie
job or what on your bucket list is movie
themes have a film made about me going
to the moon anything a bit more doable
become a star become a star I'm not
gonna happen I'll do that movie monsters
[Applause]
can we do that I want to be a monster I
just want to know what I would look like
if I was scary
I've got friendly face curse this
friendly face George Winky and
professional makeup artist UAE eye
school professional makeup how you
wanted to be turned to a monster right
I've been doing this for 10 years now
but I've been into it since I was a
young kid when I saw American Wharf in
London I mean a man turned into a wolf
right there in the camera and living I
love you
I like going to scary films I got like
taking my partner too scary film because
you're gonna hug you and says it's okay
it's fine then and it was because Nemo
found his daddy joke why no some people
can get allergic reactions to film a cup
it's safe though isn't it well ah what'd
be interesting at that so Joe's getting
made into a monster what do we do you
can actually cheer cheer yeah clap what
are we gonna do cool gel like a spa day
but we're gonna turn your ugly it's a
Joe day basically how'd you know well
I'm gonna FaceTime on mom to be honest
I'm just quite pleased that something on
his bucket list is doable there's just
complete nonsense on there
he's written eat breakfast for breakfast
lunch and dinner and cigars he eats
breakfast all the time so he's probably
achieved a lot of the things on his list
without knowing first we're gonna probe
your skin you know it doesn't get an
allergic reactions or anything like that
then are we gonna fit this see if it
fits you if I have to go adjustments are
we gonna view it click view of my face I
feel you eyebrows then we're gonna apply
the prosthetic but I wanted to get off
later I wanted to go on it maybe oh come
on now you can open your eyes oh my god
[Music]
then are we gonna paint it look like a
bull back pain a good word what's my
name
Silas they called me ha
char's likes terrible I feel transformed
George whatever you down yes love you
what oh that was stressful
bye
[Music]
it was great wouldn't know we'll do next
so you wanted to be a monster in a movie
I'm gonna be the action star I went on a
date to an action movie you're gonna get
every everyday I go on action joke send
the movie theater
I just thought over there so that's
rolls punches gonna be something we're
going to stunt school be loads of stunts
I get a body double Nicolas Cage hey my
name is Peter Lee Thomas I am a martial
artist stunt performer can we ask what
movies you put them at the moment we
just finished helping Halle Berry
prepare for John wick complete it's like
training Halle Berry or in LA like I'm
like need my star sighting he's got some
weird stuff this guy so I'm bringing out
gun stunts like falling out of a window
I have I used to work solely as a stunt
performer we were gonna have you fall
off something he wouldn't want to do
stunt school we're gonna set him on fire
and then we're gonna just launch him off
the building it's perfect I think he's
chosen this just to make me feel
uncomfortable and it's works you seen
the guys rich rich wants to be by this
Peter guy when you have to do 20 takes
of a certain movement you don't have the
fitness you have nothing
we're gonna make sure we do that so
hopefully you didn't have a heavy lunch
I'm super good Oh perfect if anyone's
gonna pass out it's gonna be me so we're
gonna first start off with just a
general warmup
right cross we're gonna learn how to
slip out of bobbin weave very nice
really how to sell a punch I'll take the
reaction rate so if you're in the next
rocky needy this is the stuff that you
learn and then we're gonna maybe play
with some sorts
[Music]
what about disarming a gun absolutely
and then have it from here this is to
say it looks bad Nicolas Cage I think
which is trying to impress the guy I
like to be friends with them
just be cool cool that I'd hang out with
and I don't think the guys in dress
[Music]
how exhausted he was very cool some
smooth skin he was impressed what are we
doing is yours
[Music]
we're gonna become action figures you're
gonna become your very own action figure
in that and that this is me as an action
figure
yes you're the one from Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles I had a crush on Raphael
right you got a glow so - Raphael or the
crush on a massive town hey welcome to
do
[Music]
I'm calling cable and I'm the store
manager here at duke3d here in Los
Angeles you capture memories of you
action figures like a little teeny
volumetric photo of you or Barbies this
one's me right here do we basically get
printed what we do is we have our 3d
scanner here it's gonna be the
duplicator is always associated to do
buzzer well there is a dispensary down
the block so they get a little mixed up
it's pretty much a 3d photo of yourself
what advice do you tell people when they
come to get their tube done I say be
creative you want to express yourself
and make sure it represents you know you
as as unique as you are because it is a
very like sentimental product for your
capturing this moment in time we hear it
do I thought I was gonna be sculpted all
the best movie stars have their own
action figure think Avengers Star Wars
Harry Potter I'm feeling a bit
self-conscious I don't know why I looked
like from here so who paints it so it's
actually printed right into the printer
it's a full CMYK ink injection so it's
completely photorealistic of what you
wearing dressed up I told you about
what's the most superhero like outfit
and I was like obviously a red jumpsuit
but on a cape maybe like a band didn't
have those in my closet so instead I
made my hair really frilly says a lot
about her wanting a model of herself
Joe is obviously gonna do something
weird to try to hide his chin maybe I
might just do that
so thinking this is really cool I'm just
excited to have it it should have been
on my bucket list I just want to be an
action figure
slash Barbie but we won't tell rich and
joe that but they're about to become
Barbies I'll have you stand in the
duplicator
I'm feeling the pressure you strike your
pose will count down one two three click
of a button it captures all 54 images
[Music]
and then from there we send it to our
data team and they turn it to a
volumetric photo from there we can 3d
print it and then you have your little
figure so it takes about two three weeks
to get it in the mail was pretty excited
right now
Oh weird blue this that's me
that is me
that is me the detail is amazing it's
beautiful every single crease look at
every single crease that bump I've never
seen my bum before this is a great
conversation start like how weird is
that if you arrive at someone's house
they just have a thing of themselves
it's a little vain isn't it in so many
dare we know what we do we need to
decide what belongs on the ultimate like
a list of stage makeup we turn you into
a monster which was actually pretty
amazing
done guy hasn't accepted my friend the
first so not as amazing as I originally
thought he was move on I loved all over
man Rach what do you think you're in
your action pose now after three let's
just say what we what we were feeling
are like deep down three two one action
pick up school have an action figure
made of yourself because that's the
ultimate selfie isn't it yeah
co2 that's sad what have we become
[Music]
[Music]